la clave de este gobierno como ya
sucedió en el pasado va a ser conformar
una coalición y en ella van a jugar un
papel importante los verdes y los
liberales que son partidos pequeños pero
que han salido muy fortalecidos cuál
podría ser la fórmula que usted ve más
posible
yo espero que va a haber un año para
tratar de consolidar la coalición esta
coalición va a ser muy difícil la
diferencia de votos es de alguna manera
son 10 votos en sede con el dibujo del
esperéis pero los verdes tienen
118 votos entonces vamos a tener una
agenda muy amplia tema pospandemia tenia
el tema china el tema a taiwán el tema
la alianza del acuse y el tema otan que
va a ser un tema importante en la agenda
alemana y a
vamos a ver una tensión interna
y adicionalmente tenemos la alternativa
por alemania que
alternativa por alemania tuvo 83 escaños
entonces tenemos un partido de extrema
derecha que anteriormente se llama el
ente de que va a tener de alguna manera
una fuerza en el parlamento los dificil
wagner para o las suites consolidar una
coalición tanto schulz de los
socialdemócratas como las et de esa
coalición de los conservadores han dicho
que tendrán un gobierno conformado para
la navidad de este año de no ser así
entonces angela merkel seguirá en la
cancillería de alemania se extenderá que
podrá hacer merkel entonces en ese
tiempo extra que pueda llegar a tener
recuerde usted que schultz fue ministro
de finanzas de merkel y era aprendió muy
bien de ella él sabe hacer coaliciones y
él aprendió de una digamos de una gran
política del cd&v a saber que habían
unos intereses nacionales en alemania
que ponían si los intereses en alemania
ponía o pueden poner en riesgo la unión
europea entonces alemania y eso es algo
muy importante que quiere tenerlo la
schultz en la cabeza es si no hay
coalición en diciembre vamos a tener una
unión europea sin gran bretaña
tambaleando en crisis
es decir francia
necesita de alemania
después de usted que el pib alemán es de
2.370 millones de euros y el pib de
francia es de 1300 algo 50 millones de
euros o sea la diferencia es de mil
millones de euros claro alemania es la
locomotora económica de toda la unión
europea es estabilidad sí doctor vega
para terminar llama mucho la atención
usted lo mencionaba lo fortalecido que
resultaron los verdes y los liberales
pero también el triunfo de la
ultraderecha en dos estados importantes
del este en los estados de turingia y de
sajonia que lectura se puede hacer sobre
estos tres partidos en particular que el
proyecto de integración de desde
1990 no ha funcionado
no estudie en el oriente alemán y le
puedo decir que el oriente no se siente
de alguna manera
integrado con el exigente alemán y ese
proyecto de integración parece que no ha
dado resultado
lo que es va a ver lo que es la óptica
el origen y además lo que sería esa joya
y lo que podríamos decir que es
brandenburgo no se siente integrado
cottbus de ciudades tan importantes como
halle como like si no se sienten
integradas al proyecto de desarrollo del
occidente